pues excepción de todos los eventos que
han tenido lugar en esta segunda jornada
de visita de estado se cumplió con la
agenda con el horario establecido los
las parejas presidenciales se reunieron
pasadas las siete de la noche hora de
Washington para tomarse la foto oficial
antes de la cena que están teniendo en
este momento acá en la casa blanca llegó
con un vestido del diseñador Oscar de la
Renta Y pues la número de invitados es
bastante amplio pocos periodistas
lograron entrar ahí el full de
periodistas cercano a la casa blanca
tuvo acceso y ha descrito además pues la
vestimenta también de La La La La La
primera dama de Francia también muy
elegante han descrito los periodistas
ya habíamos descrito que la música que
está en este momento tocándose desde
yang Batista pero hay que mencionar
también que
Manuel estuvo en el congreso antes de
llegar acá a la casa blanca a la cena de
estado bueno hice hemos dicho que lo más
destacado de la jornada fue justamente
el anuncio de biden sobre las
modificaciones a la ley de reducción de
la inflación Por qué preocupado a Europa
esta normativa
pues preocupa Europa porque hay empresas
que están vendiendoles semiconductores y
otros otros herramientas otros elementos
a Estados Unidos cuando Estados Unidos
pues decide sacar adelante esta ley que
subsidia a empresas estadounidenses para
producir sus propios semiconductores su
propia tecnología pues Esto hace que la
la competitividad y la competencia de
empresas europeas en Estados Unidos pues
se vea amenazada precisamente dado los
subsidios que yo bailen Pues empieza a
darle a sus empresas estadounidenses no
solamente para crear mano de obra acá en
Estados Unidos sino también pues para
asegurar y dejar de depender de
potencias como yo baiden lo dijo sobre
todo de China no quiere seguir
dependiendo de China y quieren
fortalecer la mano de obra
estadounidense